bonjour salut je suis la preuve et si
vous êtes sur cette vidéo normalement
vous le savez parce qu'on est sur ma
chaîne mais là aujourd'hui je suis ici
pour vous parler de quelque chose qui va
un petit peu plus loin que ce que je
fais d'habitude et c'est pour ça que je
suis accompagné de loups bonjour encore
et du coup je te laisse te présenter
accor tout de go à cake
ah non moi du coup de ces loups etc et
échoue parce que c'est bien son nom bon
bah là puisque il ya des gens pensent
que c'est pas mon vrai prénom voilà oui
non je suis j'ai une petite chaîne qui
s'appelle the life of war sur laquelle
je fais entre autres de la fiction et
quelque chose me dit que c'est un
rapport avec ce qu'on m'a présenté
aujourd'hui mais tout à fait loup parce
que nous sommes ici pour vous présenter
un projet d'une web série que j'ai
écrite il ya quelques mois déjà et j'en
avais parlé un tout petit peu sur la
vidéo des trois ans en disant je la
ferai peut-être un jour eh bien là c'est
un petit peu plus concret on lance cette
web série
ce jour est arrivé mais ce jour étape et
c'est pour ça que je me fais accompagner
de loups qui sera co réalisatrice sur ce
projet et compagnes et de plein d'autres
gens bien aussi et on va donc vous
présenter un peu tout ça dans cette
vidéo tout à fait donc 7 cv ça s'est
basé pour ceux qui souffrent ni de
preuve sur les personnages que vous
voyez apparaître de temps en temps
aliénor lucrecia la romaine et d'autres
personnages si vous n'avez jamais vu
chronique de profs vous pourrez tout à
fait comprendre par contre mais donc le
départ c'est pourquoi ces gens qui
viennent d'époques différentes se
retrouve-t-il au 21ème siècle en faisant
des vidéos en plus j'ai donc repris les
personnages de chroniques de profs pour
raconter une histoire de science fiction
dans laquelle on aura du voyage
l'entendent
moore tout ce qu'on aime quoi et nous
allons l'expliquer dans cette web série
qui comprendra six épisodes de qualité
mais pour ça on a quand même un petit
budget à la besoin d'aucune tout à fait
parce que là il faut pouvoir déjà un
homme d'effrayer les gens éventuellement
acheter louer du matériel payer les
nourrir oui nous verrons j'avais bien
payer les repas mais manger mais moi
donc voilà on a fait un budget au
minimum ça serait bien qu'on puisse
réunir 1200 euros qui nous permettrait
vraiment de faire la base de tout ce
qu'on vient de présenter mais après on
peut envisager plus puisque comme c'est
de la science fiction il y aura
forcément des petits effets spéciaux a
ajouté et je suis pas une spécialiste
d'after effects donc si on peut trouver
de moi non plus c'est mieux
voilà et pour ça donc vous retrouverez
sur le projet ulule différents paliers
qui nous permettront de faire des choses
de mieux en mieux
selon ce qu'on avait à rassembler et
pour ça on aura différents personnages
puisque d'habitude j'incarne tout le
monde mais là ça va être un peu
compliqué donc il y aura différentes
personnes qui joueront différentes
versions de moi et ce sont des gens très
bien qu'on va trouver donc on aura pour
jouer
lucrecia on aura clemi de la chaîne
chris noth que vous dire si vous
connaissez ma chaîne vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vu dans beaucoup de mes
vidéos et notamment apprendre la magie à
la cagnotte oui voilà plein de trucs
comme ça et elle fait aussi des choses
cool de son côté rui plainte au cou
ne pourront jouer astrid nous aura une
excellente actrice qui s'appelle léa et
qui va donner du fil à retordre à bien
badass qui va être bien ce nous est
clairement à strictement ne connaissait
pas d'ailleurs mais que le découvrir
dans la série
voilà on sait pas qui est astrid je
n'avais jamais nommé à il ya une astrid
que vous avez déjà vu dans les vidéos et
vous savez pas qui c'est ensuite on aura
d'autres personnages et parce que toi du
coup tu joueras moi je le jouerai la
prof forcément et j'aurai un mineur
parce que j'aime jouer a dit non donc je
me lagarde celle là et ombres d'autres
personnages bien sûr puisqu'on jouait
entre autres par florence trivières qui
est une comédienne que j'aime beaucoup
qui participent à plein de projets bien
dont sans vouloir vous déranger que vous
voyez ici et on aura aussi guillaume que
cour trouve d'habitude sur la chaîne
musée aux notes qui parle d'histoire de
l'art et qui participera au projet du
coup niveau tournage pour l'instant on a
prévu trois week-ends donc 1 en juin et
2 fin août avec une potentielle date de
diffusion que c'est plus qu'en bas le
temps de monter tout ça ça demandera un
prêt de 2,6 à différentes personnes qui
travaillent sur le mental donc enfin fin
2018 dès mes débuts je sais faire 2018
je pense qu'il ya moyen qu'on commence à
diffuser
moi ça fait on va tourner dans des lieux
divers et variés ça sera bien et donc
donc si ça vous intéresse n'hésitez pas
à lire toutes les informations sur la
page du nul et a participé
financièrement si vous en avez envie
oui et ça me ferait très plaisir et bien
sûr il y aura des contreparties que vous
retrouvez aussi sur les bulles vous
aurez tous les détails et notamment je
pense qu'on mettra en place une
newsletter aussi pour les personnes qui
auront contribué pour que vous voyez où
en est ce projet comment on avance un
prêtre oui clairement
lentement mais sûrement et du coup on
vous dis à très vite un très bientôt
en tout cas sur ma chaîne vous
retrouverez pas il ya deux vidéos qui
sortent en avril en plus de celle ci
donc vous allez avoir plein de nouvelles
choses historique et dans tous les cas
même si le projet de l'observer sont en
place je continue à faire prenez deux
profs à côté voilà merci à lui ai dit au
revoir et nous allons l'expliquer dans
c'est dans cette petite série qui
comprendra 8 et piteusement saison c'est
bien là la mauve sait de quoi elle parle
c'est mon fils qui a du goût et du coup
au niveau des dates de tournage pour
l'instant on a prévu le week-end donc un
aura un ange humain normalement trois
week end familial à 2 fin août
oui oui c'est plus la meuf sait de quoi
elle parle
oui mais vous avez